every video you send me which is often
you send me a lot of videos throughout
the course of the day is always of a
buff
guy doing something and it sucks so much
that you send me that and I tell you all
the time why do you send me this I don't
want to see this I don't care it's not
even at all something I'd ever want to
look at two hours later maybe less you
send me another one I work out 7 days a
week every morning at this gym in my
town
and about a month and a half ago the gym
closed down for the club scrub which is
like cleaning reorganization whatever so
the day it opened they had donuts for
everyone and while I was leaving I
wasn't going to grab a doughnut because
I just worked out and didn't e a donut
yeah but one of the trainers told me to
grab one so I grabbed two because I have
two little kids at home that would love
a donut and he made a joke to me like oh
yeah I bet those are for your kids or
whatever right well it was reality it
wasn't J well since that day a month and
a half ago go oh no I see him about 5
days a week and he has made a donut joke
to me every time I've seen it some days
it's oh is your protein doughnut
flavored or as I'm leaving he will ask
me if I'm heading to the jelly donut or
one time I was warming up on the
treadmill and he drew a picture of a
donut on a sticky note and came and
stuck it on my treadmill and he losing
his mind ha rude I don't like awkward
situations but this is to the point like
it is so notun and I try to avoid him at
the gym CU I know a donut joke's
coming and I don't know what to say to
him so please help me out with some
advice thanks oh dude that I have one
question to clarify is it her trainer or
a trainer no just a trainer at the gym
oh okay okay okay why dude this is crazy
how can somebody think that this is
still funny to do it's actually not
funny once but if you do it once or
twice I understand you don't really get
the language of humor you're just trying
to flirt with her you want to say
something three more than three times
dude you know how not funny it is it's
so not funny that a it's doubly not
funny in this way right it's not funny
cuz it's just not funny yeah but on top
of that it's not funny like a character
like that would be in a movie in a bad
comedy who like does those that kind of
stupid joke and it's like even even as
like an idiot it's not like to make fun
of the person that's not funny that does
it it's not funny like that just sucks
in every level it is it is a four
quadrant suery four quadrant sucker it
is a four qu quadrant sucker uh and the
Post-it note that's just I almost feel
like he's trolling you but he not he's
not right but but I mean that is so that
sucks man whenever this stuff happens my
first thought is always he's like in a
in a utterly boneheaded way just
flirting with well he yeah I mean he is
he wouldn't do it well maybe he might do
it to a guy I don't know I mean I get
weirdos come up to me do [__] like that
but maybe it's cuz they they don'tbe
yeah [__] like that yeah maybe CU like
like like they know who I am or
something I don't know what does she say
what how dides she get it to stop do not
make a donut joke anymore what do not
make a donut joke anymore and then he
would make a joke about how that yeah
you would say do not make a joke he say
oh you said donut yeah
uh that's horeshit that sucks dude but
what does she do don't cough
um that's oh God I mean I would say that
like 85 to 90% of the time the advice is
just be straight up with the person
whatever you call in or you you you you
do video
in but you're just no matter what
honestly dude somebody who does that no
matter what happens you're going to get
guess what he guess what he gifted you
awkwardness no matter what yeah cuz now
either it's going to be awkward because
the donut J joke and you're going to be
like or you're going to say something
and it's going to be awkward from then
on seeing him that isn't doing the donut
joke but here's the thing when someone
sucks that much why are you awkward why
you why do you have to feel awkward this
guy sucks I I I I understand that and
you and I get that but I get why she is
but I'm trying to con I'm trying to
convey to her like this guy sucks to
such a degree that it think about it
this way like let that minimize or or or
even erase the potential awkwardness of
saying hey stop like this isn't funny
you do it every time I see you it makes
me feel like I have to laugh but it's so
not funny I can't like just don't do
that or just yeah that would be great if
you said exactly or well it would be or
you could just be like oh another dut
joke great oh another keep doing that
he'll get the hint but then he might
think you're flirting back or Worse do
it more oh you're right dude you know
yeah if he's like one of our parents
friends I'll tell you who it is later
after the show yeah dude that's crazy
you know what this is one of those
[__] things it's just too bad yeah
it's just a shame you know what it is
you're a chick and this is the [__] that
chicks have to deal with it sucks dude
it sucks and I get a little bit of that
because you know when I walk in somebody
might make a joke about something I did
or you know because they know me and
[__] but man being a chick is like naada
dude it's
unbelievable you know it just not like
being a man that's for sure yeah hell
yeah man that's not what I meant red
blooded American mans no mans you know
well uh I just yeah that's annoying
that's just some chick [__] it is you
just got to deal with
it she should say something well yeah
but she still will have to deal with it
is my point even after yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah but if she's going to
have to deal with it anyway she should
say something don't ever pretty much
ever talk to anyone at gyms pretty much
that is the rule it's pretty much the
rule but uh you know maybe like oh
you're using that or oh obviously you
can communicate
with write little notes uh yeah yeah uh
that's that's tough man he just how do
how do people not know that rule that
seems like one of the most obvious rules
that there is there's no obvious rules
people are dumb especially men well
obviously but saying that seems so
obvious it's it to break that rule you
got to be a big idiot there was a woman
there's a woman at my gym and she
comes in you know she's a little older
um she always seems No
Nonsense do not approach me uh in the
zone works out hard it's cool
and I was just like that's a woman that
you don't does anybody hit on her
uh have you ever seen somebody uh no I
haven't seen anybody do it no I've seen
it like three or four times
right um I am I I noticed she's on the
machine that I want to go to right okay
so I'm I'm not going to ask her when
she's done I'm not going to I'm just
going to assume that you know she'll be
done and I'll pick it up right so I go
to uh stand kind of near it but not to
where she's like oh he's waiting for it
do you know what I'm saying okay so I go
there and uh I I have like half of a
water bottle full and I there's a wall
and I go to kind of like instead of
bending it down and placing it on the
floor I just kind of like Chuck it over
there to see if I can get it to stand up
against the wall I'm also very very very
out of breath because I work out like a
monster okay now you're getting
sidetracked in a way I don't like my
delts they get big when I work out I
look very [__] I'm look massive so I
do it and I go oh and she says
uh wow somebody's angry so loud whoa and
I it [__] me up so much because she
did not seem like somebody she was
making like a being silly oh yeah not M
you know cuz I wasn't angry I was just
she was making a joke like oh you threw
it down hard and I was like I didn't
know what to say and I finally mustered
out oh yeah dude I would have B down and
put it put it on the ground but no extra
movement except for the exercises it's
all for the exercises and she
went really loud like not like that but
like you know what I mean and I was like
you never really can judge a book by it
cover you never know yeah no it's true
yeah she's very sweet I mean I'm not
making fun of her I'm just you could not
have guessed that yeah you're crazy so
uh uh why do I say that I have no idea
gym related I guess why did I say it
probably just because you wanted to talk
about being at the gym because it's all
you ever talk
about those guys are too big I mean I
know why are we looking at fascinating
dude dude it's not that fascinating is
fascinating because they're two [__] F
big and it's obvious what are they doing
that always looking at him you look at
him so much but because it's just
fascinating 20% of his day he's looking
at really big buff dudes yep that's I
mean not 20% but a lot I just 20% but
it's not wow it it it's not a oh that's
great thing it's just like what the [__]
yeah a lot of them are short and you're
like what well if you're going to be
that big be big and tall dude no but I
mean I think the obvious thought I know
I yes yes but guy we we can see what's
going on here I mean some women like
that though some women are into that
really really buff a limited amount of
women I think limited limited edition I
think it's more than a little amount
minuscule amount no it's it's it's then
why do they do it because dude they're
[__] why does the guy write Donuts to
the [__]
lady's being funny delusional just like
the other [__] short big dudes right
but no dude okay I mean I don't know how
to prove it but this is my actual belief
I think more than we realize cuz
obviously my whole life I've never been
like a big muscly dude and I in PE guys
in my friends in my Orbit are not either
so I don't really have any experience
with how
people but I my sense is that why else
would guys do that to their bodies if
not to like enhance their chances
with in what significant other whatever
but that doesn't mean but okay we're
talking you're talking about muscles on
muscles yeah I am a good body is
different no I know yes yeah we're
talking about the same thing okay yeah
no I had one girlfriend that I dated
that was like I I like that I would date
a guy like that and I was like no like
really really big and she's like yeah I
think it's I think it's good-looking
there you go and I was but that's one
out of oh my God how many girls have I
dated dated seriously not that many not
that many like you've had you know not
that many anyway I'm a lonely Soul I'm
aolf anyway I'm right